I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. I love it. Creed is here.
我是珍娜·费舍（Jenna Fisher），我是安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）。我们一起演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎，我太爱了。克里德在这里。
Creed is here. Creed is here. Creed is here. Creed is in the house. This is so amazing. Creed is going to be with us for the whole episode, guys. Okay, Creed, you are our first in-house visitor, right? I mean, we've had people call in, but you're our first in-house guest.
克里德在这里。克里德在这里。克里德在这里。克里德大驾光临。这太棒了。克里德将和我们一起录制整集节目，伙计们。好吧，克里德，你是我们的第一位现场来宾，对吧？我的意思是，我们之前有连线过其他人，但你是我们的第一位现场嘉宾。
I'm the first one. I might have a bathroom break or something. It won't be for the whole thing, but I'll be in and out. We can provide you with a bathroom break. That'd be good. I'm old. I'm old school. Well, I'm old, so that's part of it, you know.
我是第一个。我可能得去上个厕所什么的。不会待满全场，但我会进进出出。我们可以为你安排上厕所的时间。那挺好的。我老了。我是老派。嗯，我老了，所以这也是原因之一，你知道的。
I need everybody to know that I've already teared up twice since Creed has been here. And you've said two touching, well, first of all, just seeing you, almost burst into tears, but then you've said like five amazing things that have touched my heart already. Well, as soon as I get together with you, it's just back and we're back on the set, you know, and it's all like, oh, I miss you girls. Creed lives down the street from me. I think everybody who knows me knows this. The world knows that.
我需要让大家知道，自从克里德来这里之后，我已经感动落泪两次了。而且你已经说了两句感人——首先，光是看到你，我就差点哭出来；但接着你又说了大约五句惊艳的话，已经触动了我的心。嗯，一跟你聚在一起，那种感觉就全回来了，就像我们回到了片场，你知道的，然后大家就会觉得，哦，我好想念你们这些女孩。克里德就住在离我几条街的地方。我想每个了解我的人都知道这一点。全世界都知道。
Don't give him my address, please. I won't. Creed's address is. His hidden key is, yes, we are neighbors, and it's one of the joys of my life that we're neighbors. I love that. You're right around the corner. I love that we have.
请别把我的地址告诉他。我不会的。克里德的地址是……他藏备用钥匙的地方是……是的，我们是邻居，能成为邻居是我人生中的乐事之一。我太喜欢这样了。你就住在转角。我喜欢我们有……
We see each other walking. We see each other walking. We see each other hiking around the street. We do. Hey. You were walking. Was it your daughter's dog? Your son's dog.
我们看到彼此散步。我们看到彼此散步。我们看到彼此在街区附近远足。我们确实如此。嘿。你当时在散步。那是你女儿的狗吗？你儿子的狗。
My son's little Yorkie, yeah. Little Yorkie. And I hear, hey, pumpkin. And I turn around and it's Creed. And we've also maybe had some adult beverage and in red solo cups. We may have. We may have. And we like to do a little bit of what we call the sauce trail and walk around having
我儿子的约克夏小狗，对。小约克夏。然后我听到有人喊，嘿，小南瓜。我转过身一看，是克里德。而且我们可能还喝了一些成人饮料，装在红色的塑料杯里。我们可能喝过。我们可能喝过。我们喜欢做一点我们称之为“美酒小径”的事情，边走边喝
a glass of wine. And watching documentaries. Oh, yeah. Creed loves. I think we're like animals go crazy like planet earth. Yes. All that stuff. I just love it.
一杯葡萄酒。还看纪录片。哦，是的。克里德喜欢……我觉得我们就像动物一样疯狂，比如《地球脉动》。是的。诸如此类的东西。我就是喜欢。
All right. Well, we are really excited to have you here. We are discussing the Halloween episode. Yes. Right. Right. Season two, episode five. This was written by Greg Daniels and directed by Paul Feig.
好吧，很高兴你能来到这里。我们正在讨论万圣节那一集。是的。没错。第二季第五集。这一集由格雷格·丹尼尔斯（Greg Daniels）编剧，保罗·费格（Paul Feig）执导。
And it is the first episode that Creed speaks. Well, I actually spoke in diversity day. In diversity, I had lines with Phyllis and they paid me afterwards and well, the first day, the girl we had the first day, the first season, she thought it was part of the cast at the time. So Kate, she came in with her little hands and she said, now you and Phyllis just start talking and Phyllis said, wait, I said, never mind. It's okay.
这也是克里德开口说话的第一集。嗯，其实我在《多元化日》里说过话。在《多元化日》里，我和菲莉丝有台词，他们事后付了我片酬，嗯，第一天，我们第一天遇到的那个女孩，第一季的那位，她当时以为我是演员阵容的一员。所以凯特，她挥着小手走过来对我说，现在你和菲莉丝开始说话吧，然后菲莉丝说，等等，我说，没关系。没关系。
Never mind. Phyllis was going to get out of you. Phyllis was going to get out of me. So I never mind. It's fine. And so we started. I started talking about, you know, sacrificing goats or something, you know, trying to tell her what was on her head.
没关系。菲莉丝本来要把你的台词套出来。菲莉丝本来要从我这套出……所以，没关系。这很好。于是我们开始了。我开始谈论，你知道的，献祭山羊什么的，你知道的，试图告诉她她头上顶着什么。
You're improv with sacrificing goats. Yes. Yes. And then they said, wait a minute, Creed's talking in the background. And they said, oh shoot, how did that happen? Yeah. How'd that happen, Creed? And so, so they, they, they paid me on the side, but they didn't say, but we can't.
你的即兴表演是关于献祭山羊的。对的。对的。然后他们说，等等，克里德在背景里说话了。他们说，哦糟糕，怎么会这样？是的。怎么会这样，克里德？所以，所以他们，他们私下里付了我片酬，但他们没有说，不过我们不能……我说，不，这很好。这很好。然后镜头之外，还有游乐设施的配音。是的。矿山车的配音。为了矿山车，你知道的。你太搞笑了。我想他们对那个很关注。
I said, no, it's fine. It's fine. And then off camera, then also was the voice for the, the ride. Yes. For the mining ride. For the mining ride, you know. You were so funny. I think they paid, they paid attention to that one.
是的。你作为矿山车配音实在是太搞笑了，伊莎贝尔当时正和我一起看那一集，她说，妈妈，我知道那个声音。我知道那个声音。然后我就想，等等，你是，哦天哪，她就说，我猜是克里德。她，我很敏锐地发现是她。她就是。我的意思是，我当时没听出来。
Yeah. You were so funny as the voice of the mining ride and Isabelle was watching that episode with me and she said, mom, I know that voice. I know that voice. And I was like, wait, you're, oh my gosh, she was like, I think it's Creed. She, I'm discerning to she. She is. I mean, I didn't catch it.
然后我查了一下，我说，伊莎贝尔，我们确实知道那个声音。那是克里德。是的。不过不管怎样，这是我真正拥有一些严肃台词的第一次。那有六页半。我记得肯·扎博尔内克（Kent Zabornek）把剧本往桌上一扔，说道：“好了，就是这样。这是你的，这是你的时刻。”
And then I looked it up and I'm like, Isabelle, we do know that voice. It's Creed. Yeah. But anyway, this is the first time where I actually was, was, had some, had some serious lines. It was six and a half pages. I remember Kent Zabornek threw the script down and said, okay, here it is. This is your, this is your moment.
哇。我把它正着背、倒着背都记熟了。我在夜里在一个小录音机上设置了一个定时器，在潜意识里两点和三点时它会响起来，在我睡觉的时候播放台词。克里德。我把它正着反着都背熟了。不开玩笑。我背得滚瓜烂熟。
Wow. And I, I had memorized it forwards and backwards. I had set a timer on a little recorder at a night, subliminally at two and three in the morning that it would go off and play the lines while I was sleeping. Creed. I had it backwards and forth. No joke. I had it back.
哇。我知道这是卢比孔河（意指背水一战）。这是我要取得突破的地方。我的直觉告诉我，就是这个。然后当然，我们走进办公室，格雷格他们进来后说：“顺便说一句，我们对台词做了一些更改，把它们前后颠倒了，还加了一些新东西。你还好吗？”
Wow. I knew this was the Rubicon. This is the place that I was going to get. My intuition said, this is it. And then of course we walk in the office and Greg, they came in and said, by the way, we made changes of course to the, to the, to the lines and we've reversed them around, add some new stuff. You okay?
他说，嗯，挺好。我说，哦。因为他们以前经常对我们这么做。一直都是。我们会走进来，然后你就会拿到新的剧本页，接着在五分钟后拍摄这个场景。是的。他们会把剧本页交给你，有时候我们聊过这个，剧本页都还是热的。
He goes, yeah, fine. I go, oh. Cause they used to do that to us. All the time. We would come in and you'd just get new pages and then shoot the scene five minutes later. Yeah. They would hand you the pages and sometimes we've talked about this, the pages would be hot.
刚从复印机里出来。刚从复印机里出来。我们甚至还会掉……是的。哎哟，哎哟，哎哟，哎哟。现在改吧，改掉你已经学会的台词，改掉那个让你在凌晨三点听录音机播放的台词。你还记得我桌子和凯特桌子旁边的那个背景吗？
Right off the copier. Right off the copier. And we'd drop them some. Yeah. Ow, ow, ow, ow. Now change, now change your lines that you have learned and you've been having a tape recorder play at three in the morning to you. Do you remember the backdrop there right off of where my desk and, and Kate's desk was
那个隔断后面可以走人，你可以从后面偷偷溜过去通往化妆休息室。是的。是的。就是那样设置的。他们告诉我这个之后，我往后退成那样，双手举起来说：“好吧，就是这样。”然后我说，“我走了这么远。”
and the screen is so you can walk, you can sneak around the back and get to the green room from behind it. Yeah. Yeah. That set up like that. I walked back like that after they told me this and put my hands up and said, okay, here it is. And I said, I've come this far.
我要把这个演下来。一旦我们和史蒂夫（Steve）开始那样对戏，就像是上了战场，你知道的。是的。那一场戏有一些即兴发挥，因为我是在意译我的台词，因为我当时走投无路了。嗯，你大获成功，克里德。是的。是的。
I'm going to do this. And once we started that with Steve, it was like into, into battle, you know. Yeah. And it was like some improvisation on that scene because I, I was paraphrasing my lines because I was desperate. Well, you knocked it out of the park, Craig. Yeah. Yeah.
嗯，克里德，你一开始是个音乐家。是的。作为一名音乐家，你有着非常漫长且成功的职业生涯。你当初怎么会作为我们的替身兼背景演员来到这个节目的？背景演员。我当时在拍《伯尼·麦克秀》（Bernie Mac），肯·夸帕斯（Ken Kwapis）来执导其中一集，他们一直让我演这些小片段，我在里面做一些搞笑的动作。
Well, Craig, you started out as a musician. Yeah. And a very long successful career as a musician. How did you even end up on the show in the first place as our stand in slash background person? Background person. I was working on Bernie Mac and Ken Quapas came on to direct an episode and they'd been using me for all these little vignettes and where I was doing funny.
如果你看过老版的《伯尼·麦克秀》，你会发现我一直在背景里做鬼脸。我真想看看那个。我想回去看看。我总是在背景里做一些蠢事，他们只是允许我这么做，因为我把伯尼逗笑了。我把他们都逗笑了。所以肯就说这家伙很有趣，他从第一助理导演乔·穆尔（Joe Moore）那里听说
And if you ever watch old Bernie Mac, you'll see me all the time in the background mugging up. I really want to see that. I want to go back. I'm always in the background doing some stupid stuff and they just allow me because I made Bernie laugh. I made them laugh. And so Ken was talking about this guy's funny and he heard from Joe Moore, the first AT
我在草根乐队（The Grass Roots）待过。所以他派人去阿米巴唱片行（Amoeba）买了一些专辑让我签名，因为他是草根乐队的超级粉丝。我们开始聊天，聊到音乐，他非常博学。后来我发现他正在制作《办公室：美国职场》（The Office: An American Workplace），我是瑞奇·热维斯（Ricky Gervais）节目的超级粉丝。于是他给了我他的电话号码。现在，我以前从来没有给这样的人打过电话。我给他打了电话，因为我的直觉告诉我，这感觉很对。
that I was on in the grassroots. So he sent to Amoeba for some albums for me to sign because he was a big grassroots fan. And we started talking and talked about music and he's very knowledgeable. Then I found out that he was doing the Office of American Workplace and I was a big fan of the Ricky Gervais show. So he gave me his number. Now, I've never, ever called anybody like that before. I called him as my intuition said, this feels right.
这感觉很对。而且肯本来是不会把电话号码给你的。我觉得肯是那么严苛的一个人。天哪。他并不是真的让我打电话给他。是的。是的。所以他真的打了。
This feels right. And Ken would not have given you his number. I feel like Ken is so discerning. Oh my God. He didn't mean call me. Yeah. Yeah. So he did.
然后他跟格雷格谈了，后来我跟肯谈过，他说：“我跟格雷格谈过了。我告诉他，你是个非常有趣和搞笑的家伙，他说，好吧，我们要做的就是——这是他的原话，格雷格的原话——‘我们把他放在背景里，看看能不能在第一次时把他融进群戏里。’”那是融入群戏。我只需要听到这个。这就是为什么我有点擅作主张，假装自己是这个群体的一部分，而这得到了回报。
And so he talked to Greg and then I talked to Ken later and he said, I talked to Greg. I told him, you're a very interesting and funny guy and he said, well, what we'll do and this is his words, Greg's words, we'll put him in the background and see if we can work him in the mix in that first time. That was working in the mix. That's all I need to hear. That's why I took liberties just kind of like pretending that I was a part of the part of the group and that paid off.
你知道吗？是的。哦，我太喜欢这样了。哦，这太棒了。这太棒了。接下来是什么？我们要做个总结吗？珍娜，你有一个吗？
You know? Yes. Oh, I love that. Oh, that is awesome. That is awesome. What's next? Should we do a summary? Jenna, do you have one?
你知道我有的。是的。所以在这一集中，“万圣节”，迈克尔被告知，由于邓德米夫林（Dunder Mifflin）的精简裁员，他必须在十月份期间解雇一个人。但秉持着迈克尔一贯的作风，他一直拖到十月的最后一天，而那天恰好也是万圣节。而且他根本不知道该解雇谁。他还没有做出决定。
You know I do. Yes. So in this episode, Halloween, Michael is told that he must fire someone during the month of October due to cutbacks at Dunder Mifflin. But in true Michael fashion, he waits until the very last day of October, which also happens to be Halloween. He also has no idea who to fire. He has not made a decision.
他花了整整一集的时间试图弄清楚该怎么做，而我们其他人则穿着万圣节派对的服装。我太喜欢这个了。我太喜欢这个了。我非常喜欢这种对比：一个人将要被解雇，身上却穿着滑稽的服装，然后他们还得穿着那身行头被解雇回家。好吧，关于这一集我有一个冷知识，冷知识一，格雷格·丹尼尔斯写了这一
He spends the entire episode trying to figure out what to do while the rest of us are dressed in our costumes for the Halloween party. I love that. I love that. So much. I love the juxtaposition of that someone is going to get fired while wearing a ridiculous costume and they're going to have to go home fired in that outfit. Well, I have a fast fact about this episode, fast fact number one, Greg Daniels wrote this
集，他告诉我这一集的灵感来自于他一直想拍一个关于某人被解雇的故事，但视角是从老板的角度，而不是员工的角度。他觉得我们总是看到关于人们被解雇以及他们如何纠结于自己被解雇的故事。但他说，你永远看不到这对老板有什么影响。这就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的天才之处。绝对是的。
episode and he told me that the inspiration for this episode was that he had always wanted to do a story about someone being fired, but from the point of view of the boss rather than the employee. He felt like we always see stories of people being fired and how they're wrestling with having been fired. But he was like, you never see what it does to the boss. That's the genius of Greg Daniels right there. Absolutely.
这个情节给格雷格带来的问题是，他必须在剧里解雇某人。他必须挑选一个邓德米夫林的员工来加入这个情节。嗯，他不能解雇任何常规演员，因为我们都有合同，而且他不想解雇任何配角，尽管此时你们俩还没有全职合同，对吧？直到《酒船派对》（Booze Cruise）我们才成为常规演员，所以听着，我们当时都在待宰的羔羊之列。
The problem that this plot presented for Greg was that he was going to have to fire someone on the show. He was going to have to pick a Dunder Mithlin employee to be part of the plot. Well he couldn't fire any of the series regular characters because we all had contracts and he didn't want to fire any of the supporting cast even though at this point you guys still did not have your full-time contracts, right? We didn't become series regulars till booze cruise, so listen, we were all on the chopping line.
当你看到这部剧时，你有点担心吗？也许吧。嗯，格雷格根本没有打算失去他们。他不想失去仓库里的任何人，但他也告诉我，他不想随便雇一个你从未在剧里见过的新人来解雇他。他觉得那样赌注会显得非常人为做作。于是他转向了我们的两个背景演员，克里德和德文（Devon），他当时想，好吧，这几个人在剧里已经很有知名度了。
Were you a little worried when you saw the show? Maybe. Well, Greg didn't have any intention of losing them. He didn't want to lose anyone in the warehouse, but he also told me he didn't want to hire someone new that you'd never seen on the show just to fire them. He felt like those stakes would feel very manufactured. So he turned to our two background actors, Creed and Devon, and he was like, well, these guys are very well established on the show at this point.
这就是我想知道发生了什么的地方，因为我知道这个故事的结局，那就是格雷格发现德文有一份戏剧合同即将到来，他要跟着一出话剧去巡演。所以这就是德文说的。不过当时，他们对我们说：“你们其中一个人得走，但我们还不知道是谁。我们会把你们两个人的镜头都拍下来，看看效果如何。”哦，天哪。
And this is where I'd like to know what happened because I know the end of this story, which is that Greg found out that Devon had a theater contract coming up that he was going to go on tour with a play. And so that's what Devon said. At the time, though, they told us, one of you guys are going to have to go, but we don't know yet. We're going to shoot you both and see how it works out. Oh, my God.
等等，他们要把这个场景拍两个版本？他们知道我们要拍这个，因为他们本可以回过头去修改的，我确信。哦，因为迈克尔本可以这么说：“你知道吗？我说过，是克里德，那就是克里德？你改变不了我的决定。”但注定是我们其中一个人。他们说注定是我们其中一个人。
Wait, they're going to shoot the scene two ways? They know that we're going to shoot the thing because they could have gone back and changed it, I'm sure. Oh, because Michael could have said, you know what? I said, is that it was Creed and it's Creed? You can't change my mind. But it was going to be one of us. They said it was going to be one of us.
我记得当时有点紧张。是的。是的。是的。德文和我是朋友。到这个时候我们已经成朋友了。顺便说一句，你知道的，在大结局时，跳跃到很后面，我不知道我能不能就这样跳到后面。
And I remember being a little nervous. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And Devon and I were friends. We'd become friends by this time. And by the way, you know, on the finale, jumping ahead a lot, I don't know if I could just kind of jump ahead.
是的，我可以。当格雷格把我叫进办公室，想弄清楚我想为克里德这个角色做些什么时，我说：“嗯，我有一件想做的事是唱这首歌，唱我的歌，但我也觉得我们应该让德文回到剧里。”哦，克里德，这太好了。是的。因为我们有时会聚在一起，你知道的，喝咖啡什么的。我当时觉得很紧张，因为我有点内疚，觉得自己可能得走，但也
Yeah, I can. When Greg brought me into the office to find out what I wanted to do for the Creed character, I said, well, one thing I'd like to do is sing the song, sing my song, but I also think we should have Devon back on the show. Oh, Creed, that's nice. Yeah. Because we get together sometimes, you know, and have to have coffee and stuff like that. I was feeling nervous because I kind of was feeling bad that I might have to go, but also
觉得德文也可能得走。所以这是祸福相依的各种情况。好了。冷知识二，这是我们第一次看到潘（Pam）放下头发，而不是她平时那种半盘半夹的发型。但是猫耳朵。对我来说，这太重要了。哦，那么，克里德，如果这很重要的话，你会喜欢我的一些小卡片的。
that Devon might have to go too. So it was a mixed blessings and all that stuff. All right. Fast fact number two, this is the first time we see Pam's hair down instead of her usual half up, half down hair clip. But the cat ears. That, to me, is so important. Oh, well then, Creed, then Creed, you're going to love some of my note cards if that's
系好安全带。是的。这可是件大事。金·费里（Kim Ferry），我们的发型师，还有我、格雷格以及保罗·费格，我们开会讨论了潘的发型以及我们是否能把她的头发放下来。而且，我觉得那一定持续了30分钟。我们一直在讨论。
important. Buckle in. Yeah. That was a huge deal. Kim Ferry, our hairstylist, and me, and Greg, and Paul Feig, we all had a meeting about Pam's hair and if we could let her hair down. And it was, I mean, it must have been 30 minutes. We talked about it.
大家很担心她放下头发后会显得太漂亮了。我不记得我们是怎么获得批准的。金当时高兴坏了。我是说，金已经把我的头发用发夹夹了大概12集了。她能把头发抓蓬松，简直兴奋极了。做点不同的事。什么都行。做什么都行，只要不一样。
There was a lot of concern that she might look too pretty with her hair down. And I can't remember how we got permission. Kim was delighted. I mean, Kim had been putting my hair in a hair clip now for like 12 episodes or something. She was so thrilled to be able to scrunch it. Do something different. Anything. Anything different.
这算是一件大事。嗯，他们一直在淡化你们俩的美貌，因为他们给你们的打扮和穿的衣服。没说错。大家听到这句了吗？你反抗过吗？你反抗过吗？确实如此。
And it was kind of a big deal. Well, they were playing down both of your beauties all the time with the way they dressed you and put you in stuff. That's right. Did everyone hear that? Did you fight? Did you fight? That's true.
克里德说他们淡化了我们的美貌。但这是真的。到了后期，你们有没有去游说，拜托，就让我们展现一点，你知道的，光彩照人的样子？我记得我真的很想要唇彩。是的，诸如此类的。所以对我来说有趣的是，那是关于你发型的30分钟会议。与此同时，我去到化妆间，他们给我戴上了全套、巨大、紫色、假的假睫毛。
Creed says they played down our beauty. But it's true. Toward the end, did you guys lobby for, come on, just let us show a little bit of, you know, glowing. I remember really wanting lip gloss. Yeah, something like that. So what's funny to me is that that was a 30 minute meeting about your hair. Meanwhile, I go to hair and makeup and they put on full, enormous, purple, fake eyelashes
如果你把我这只猫的样子看仔细点，我有很大的紫色假睫毛。它们太巨大了。我甚至都很难驾驭它们。当我回看那一集时，我看起来有点困。我想那是因为我睁不开眼睛。没有开会。没有开会。
on me. If you look at me as this cat, I have big purple eyelashes. They were so huge. I had a hard time like even navigating them. Like I look, when I watch the episode, I look a little sleepy. I think it's because I couldn't open my eyes. No meeting. No meeting.
他们直接戴上，我就问：你确定吗？他们直接给我戴上了。然后其中一个编剧走到我面前，我不记得是谁了，就问：你有紫色……可能是敏迪（Mindy）。她就问：你戴了紫色睫毛吗？她可能是嫉妒了。是的。
They just put, I was like, are you sure? They just put them on me. And then one of the writers walked up to me, I can't remember who, and was like, do you have purple? It's probably Mindy. She was like, do you have purple lashes on? She might have been jealous. Yeah.
是的，她想要。她会想要那些紫色睫毛的。没人说什么。为什么安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）要戴紫色假睫毛？大家都忙着开会讨论我的头发去了。是的。是的。是的。
Yeah, she wanted them. She would want those purple lashes. No one said anything. Why is Angela Martin putting on purple fake eyelashes? Everyone was too busy meeting about my hair. Yeah. Yes. Yes.
好了。冷知识三。克里德，我不知道你是否还记得这个。安吉拉，我想你可能记得。我们拍摄万圣节那一集的那个星期，瑞奇·热维斯和史蒂芬·莫昌特（Stephen Merchant）有一天来探班了。我知道这一点，因为我有一张和他们的合照，我穿着猫咪服装，吉姆是三孔打孔吉姆，但你看不太清那些“孔”，因为他正把胳膊搭在某人肩上。所以那是我们制作人、瑞奇、史蒂芬、我和约翰的一张合影。
All right. Fast fact number three. Creed, I don't know if you remember this. Angela, I think maybe you do. The week we shot the Halloween episode, Ricky Gervais and Steven Merchant visited one day. I know this because I have a photograph with them in my cat outfit and Jim is three hole punched Jim, but you can't really see the holes because he's got his arm around someone. So it's a whole picture of our producers and Ricky and Steven and me and John.
而且我是唯一一个穿着万圣节服装的人。我喜欢想象他们是来看我演的一部戏剧，我在里面扮演一只猫什么的。你的独幕剧？因为我们看起来就像是站在后台。而你穿着猫服，是的。你是唯一一个穿戏服的人。是的，这就是我为什么知道这一点，因为我只有两张自己和瑞奇、史蒂芬的合影，其中一张就是我穿着猫咪服装的照片。
And I am the only person wearing a costume. I like to imagine that they came to see me in a play where I played a cat or something. Your one act play? Because we look like we're standing backstage. And you're in the cat, yeah. You're the only one in a costume. Yeah, this is how I know this because I only have two pictures of myself with Ricky and Steven and one of them is me in a cat costume.
我记得他们在那儿，因为我还能……我的耳朵现在还因为瑞奇·热维斯那种高亢的假声而隐隐作痛，那种笑声，模仿得太像了。他笑了。他什么都笑。他一直在笑。就像喝了点咖啡。是的。哦，顺便说一句，女士们先生们，他是最温柔的人，简直是个开心果。
I remember that they were there because I could still, my ears still hurt from that high castral toe of Ricky Gervais, the laugh that's such a good impression. He laughed. He laughed at everything. He was laughed at. It was like some coffee. Yeah. Oh, by the way, ladies and gentlemen, he is the sweetest man and just a just a joy.
好了。这些是我的冷知识。这就是我们的总结。也许我们该……我们需要上厕所吗？我们去上个厕所吧。我们去上个厕所。我刚好需要。顺便说一句，我只想说我太喜欢这些冷知识了。
All right. Those are my fast facts. That's our summary. Maybe we should do we need that bathroom break? Let's do a bathroom break. Let's do a bathroom. I could use one. By the way, I just want to say I just love these fast facts.
哦，好吧，如果你喜欢这些冷知识，那就准备好迎接小卡片吧，克里德。哦天哪，我已经迫不及待了，让我的心怦怦直跳吧。好吧。你这么说听起来有点怪。听起来怪怪的，然后我就走神了。好吧。回去。去上厕所。
Oh, well, then if you love the fast facts, get ready for the note cards, Creed. Oh my God, I can't wait to be still in my throbbing heart. Okay. Sounded a little weird when you said it like that. Started to be weird and then I drifted away. Okay. Go back. Go to the bathroom.
好吧。我们进入小卡片环节吧。可以吗？小卡片。好的。我们进入这一集。开始吧。我有一张来自片头冷开场的小卡片。
All right. Let's get into some note cards. Can we? Note cards. All right. Let's get into the episode. Let's do it. I have a note card from the cold open.
哦，冷开场是怎样的？好的。冷开场是你说简（Jan）打电话来，然后他就像，哦，迈克尔必须接电话，因为他知道他必须解雇一个人。于是他给简打电话，简的助理雪莉（Sherry）接了电话，雪莉说话超级有气势。她就说，好吧，那你打算解雇谁？然后他说，嗯，我其实不太确定。
Oh, what is the cold open of this? Okay. The cold open is you say that Jan, Jan called and he's like, oh, and Michael has to go in because he knows he has to fire someone. And so he calls Jan and her assistant, Sherry answers the phone and Sherry has so much good sass. She's like, okay, well, who are you going to fire and he goes, well, I'm not really sure.
然后她说，我们只需要名字。简需要名字。简需要名字。是的。然后他说，你觉得该解雇谁？她就说，把名字给我就行了。然后，然后他以为自己挂了电话，就说，我想解雇你。结果她还能听见。
And she's like, we just need the name. Jan needs the name. Jan needs the name. Yes. And then he's like, who would you fire? And she's like, just give me the name. And then, and then he thinks he's hung up and he's like, I'd like to fire you and she could still hear.
对吧？他说，我真希望我能解雇雪莉。雪莉。我是说，我想知道雪莉是谁。雪莉是谁？是的。我也是这么想的。所以我做的第一件事，就是去了IMDB，互联网电影资料数据库。
Right? He's like, I wish I could fire Sherry. Sherry. I mean, I want to know who Sherry is. Who is Sherry? Yes. I thought the same thing. So the first thing I did, I went to IMDB, Internet Movie Database.
我也去了。我查了这一集，未署名。未署名。雪莉是谁？雪莉是谁？我联系了戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）。他是这一集的剪辑师。伙计们，他对《办公室》无所不知。
I did too. I looked up this episode, uncredited. Uncredited. Who is Sherry? Who is Sherry? I reached out to Dave Rogers. He was the editor for this episode. You guys, he knows everything about the office.
他也不知道。这就说明问题了，因为他就像……他知道这部剧《圣经》里的所有内容。他有着百科全书般的记忆力，天哪。没人知道。听听戴夫做了什么。戴夫联系了我们的选角导演艾莉森·琼斯（Allison Jones），她去了她的仓库。哦天哪。
He didn't know. That is saying something because he is like, he knows everything in the bible of the show. He's encyclopedic memory cat. No one knows. Listen to what Dave did. Dave reached out to Allison Jones, our casting director, who went to her storage facility. Oh my Lord. Found the contracts for this episode, looked it up.
找到了这一集的合同，查了一下。哇。艾莉森，谢谢你。哦天哪。艾莉森，你就像电影《糖衣陷阱》（The Pelican Brief）里的一幕。这是《办公室》版CSI。你就像《办公室》版的CSI。是丽莎·马龙（Lisa Malone）。好吧。
Wow. Allison, thank you. Oh my gosh. Allison, you're like an episode of the Pelican Brief, an episode, the movie. This is CSI the Office. You're like CSI the Office. It is Lisa Malone. Okay.
顺便说一句，这拍摄于2005年9月13日。哇。好吧，丽莎，你演的雪莉太棒了。你演绝了。你把雪莉演活了。天哪。还有艾莉森，谢谢你。谢谢你成为我们的《办公室》版CSI。
And by the way, this was shot on September 13th, 2005. Wow. Well, Lisa, you were fantastic as Sherry. You killed it. You killed it as Sherry. Oh man. And Allison, thank you. Thank you for being our CSI the Office.
我想倒回去，安吉拉，因为我有一条笔记在你小卡片的前面。是在5秒的时候吗？是德文和克里德坐在桌子前的那个镜头吗？定场镜头。是的。是的。我也注意到了。这一集的第二个镜头就是克里德和德文坐在他们的办公桌前。
I want to go back, Angela, because I have a note that precedes your note card. Is it at five seconds? Is it the shot of Devon and Creed at their desks? The establishing shot. Yes. Yes. I noticed it too. The second shot of this episode is Creed and Devon at their desks.
我不得不猜测这绝非偶然，他们是想借此强化德文和克里德的存在，因为我们知道你们其中一个——这安排得很巧妙。这安排得很巧妙。镜头先是拍菲莉丝在化妆，然后切到坐在办公桌前的德文和克里德。嗯，迈克尔和潘的那个场景，你们还记得他是怎么戴着第二个脑袋的吗？是的。
I have to imagine this was not an accident that they wanted to drive home Devon and Creed since we know that one of you- It was well-placed. It was well-placed. It's Phyllis putting on makeup and then it goes to Devon and Creed at their desks. Well, the scene with Michael and Pam, do you guys remember how he's wearing the second head? Yes.
是的。我有两张卡片。潘走进他的办公室，他告诉她他需要解雇一个人，然后他暗示这个人也许可能是她。哦，我从这个场景里拿了两张卡片。于是潘决定迅速开始奉承他。她来了个急转弯。夸奖他的万圣节服装，然后她以最快的速度离开了房间。
Yes. I have two cards. Pam goes in his office and he tells her that he needs to fire someone and then he sort of implies maybe it could be her. Oh, I have two cards from this scene. And so Pam decides to quickly start flattering him. She pivots hard. About his costume and then she just gets out of the room as quickly as possible.
我简直没法演完那场戏。是的，听着，史蒂夫单凭自己就已经够搞笑了，但加上那个顶在史蒂夫肩膀上的额外“脑袋”，这太夸张了，而且它还会以一种诡异的方式摇晃。他是故意让它摇晃的。他超爱。他超爱晃那个东西。他超爱。只要你给他一个小猫咪——
I could not get through that scene. Yeah, listen, Steve is funny enough on his own, but Steve with that extra Steve on his shoulder, it was too much and it wobbled in a sort of weird way. He was wobbling it on purpose. He loved it. He loved wobbling that thing. He loved it. Anytime you give him a little cat.
这话听着真像。拜托，伙计们。那是个绝佳的“她才刚说过”（That's what she said）。拜托。他就是爱晃东西。他超爱晃那个东西。哦，这话听着真像。嘿！
That's what she said. Come on, guys. That was a great, that's what she said. Come on. He loves wobbling things. He loved wobbling that thing. Oh, that's what she said. Hey!
我们把它接上了。我们把它接上了。我们把它接上了。克里德，我写了什么？在3分12秒时。天哪，潘太腹黑了。当她意识到迈克尔可能会解雇她时，她立刻转头开始拍马屁。哇。
We got it back. We got it back. We got it back. Creed, what did I write? At three minutes, 12 seconds. God, Pam is diabolical. Her turn to flattery when she realizes Michael would fire her. Wow.
太腹黑了。太腹黑了。我在潘身上看到了真正狡猾的一面。如果可以的话，我想点评一下史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的精湛演技，当他试图、当他准备解雇某人时，他脸上的痛苦与煎熬。你简直能看出来。他简直快要崩溃了。他绝对快要崩溃了。
Diabolical. Diabolical. I'm seeing a real devious streak in Pam. I want to just comment, if I may, the brilliance of Steve Carell, the pain and the anguish in his face when he's trying, when he's getting ready to fire someone. You can just see it. He's just dying. He's absolutely dying.
他不是在演。在我看来，他就像一个饱受折磨的男人，被梦想和死亡折磨着。你提出这一点很有意思，克里德，因为我们讨论过很多次，迈克尔渴望受欢迎。他想和大家做朋友。他想成为派对的灵魂人物。但我觉得这一集超越了这一点。这不仅仅是因为他知道他会被……
He's not acting. To me, he looked like a man just suffering, suffering from a dream and a death. It's interesting you bring that up, Creed, because we've talked a lot about how Michael wants to be popular. He wants to be friends with people. He wants to be the life of the party. But I think this episode goes beyond that. That it isn't just that he knows that it's going to be, he's going to not be well-liked
他解雇的那个人会讨厌他。我觉得这真的，就像，我觉得它触及了一些更深层的东西。他真的不想伤害别人。对的。完全正确。是的。所以这比单纯的不受欢迎要深远得多。他的表演深深打动了我。
by the person he fires. I think it really, like, I think it touches on something. He really doesn't want to hurt someone else. Yep. That's exactly right. Yeah. So it's deeper than that, just unpopularity. I was moved by his performance in that.
哦，是的。哦，是的。我是说，是的。他演得太绝了。每到万圣节，我都会收到更多关于潘扮成猫、吉姆扮成三孔打孔男的照片。我想那是我收到的最受欢迎的万圣节装扮。我自己经常收到——好吧，就是安吉拉·马丁穿着阿盖尔纹毛衣，扎着高领毛衣和发带，手里拿着一只毛绒猫玩具，旁边站着一个穿芥末黄衬衫系着领带、
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah. I mean, yeah. He crushed it. I get more pictures at Halloween of Pam as a cat and Jim as three-hole punch. I think that is the most popular Halloween costume that I get sent to me. I get myself, well, Angela Martin in an Argyle sweater, like with a turtleneck and a headband holding a stuffed animal cat next to some guy in a mustard shirt with a tie and his
头发中分的家伙。你呢，克里德？我收到小丑的。小丑。我想以小丑的形象走进去。然后当布莱恩（Brian）来的时候，该死的，克里德，他用胯部撞了你一下——不，那是后来的剧集。后来的。
hair parted down the middle. What about you, Creed? I get the Joker. The Joker. I want to walk in as the Joker. And then when Brian comes, damn it, Creed, and he hip-checks you, no, that's a later episode. Later.
是的，那一集你们俩穿着一模一样的服装。但他差点把你撞倒。哦，是的。每次看到那个我都笑得嗷嗷叫。这是一个反复出现的梗。太精彩了，太精彩了。安吉拉，我想和你聊聊你的服装。请便。
Yeah, that way you guys are both dressed in the same costume. But he almost knocks you over. Oh, yeah. I howl every time I see it. That's a recurring thing. It's brilliant, brilliant. Angela, I want to talk to you about your costume. Please.
好的。我在数。嗯哼。你扮成了一只猫。有三只猫。菲莉丝是猫。我是猫。你是猫。
Okay. I'm counting. Mm-hmm. You're dressed as a cat. There's three cats. Phyllis is a cat. I'm a cat. You're a cat.
是的。其实我们可以快速过一遍服装清单。凯利（Kelly）是桃乐丝（Dorothy），菲莉丝、潘和安吉拉是猫，德怀特（Dwight）是西斯尊主（Sith Lord），凯文（Kevin）是邓德米夫林超级英雄，克里德是吸血鬼，奥斯卡（Oscar）是一位女士。是的。是的。我不知道她是某个具体角色的女士还是一位普通的女士。我觉得他就是一位女士。
Yes. Actually, we could do really quickly the rundown of costumes. Kelly is Dorothy, Phyllis, Pam, and Angela are cats, Dwight is a Sith Lord, Kevin is the Dunder Mifflin superhero, Creed is a vampire, Oscar is a lady. Yeah. Yeah. I don't know if she's a character lady or just a lady. I think he's a lady.
他就是一位女士。吉姆是三孔打孔吉姆，斯坦利（Stanley）没穿服装，临时工瑞恩（Ryan）没穿服装，当然迈克尔有两个脑袋。而德文是个流浪汉。德文是个流浪汉。流浪汉。是的。安吉拉，为什么你的猫只有两行胡须，而不是三行？
He's just a lady. Jim is three hole punch Jim, Stanley no costume, Ryan the temp no costume, and of course Michael has the two heads. And Devin was a tramp. And Devin was a hobo. Hobo. Yeah. Angela, why does your cat only have two lines for whiskers and not three?
珍娜，我不知道。为什么我的猫有紫色假睫毛？为什么你的猫有奇怪的猫耳朵？我的意思是，我只想说，作为办公室里常驻的猫奴，我觉得你的猫服装是最差的。为什么我有一条毛茸茸的白裙子？为什么？还带着一条巨大的尾巴，坐在上面简直是不可能完成的任务。
Jenna, I don't know. Why does my cat have purple fake eyelashes? Why does your cat have weird cat ears? I mean, I just want to say that as the resident cat lady of the office, I think you have the worst cat costume. Why do I have a fuzzy white skirt? Why? With a giant tail that was almost impossible to sit in.
太难了，而且裙子不太合身，总是往下掉。我不得不一直去抓它把它往上提。那只猫简直毁了整整一集。我想现在回想起来，当时大家花了那么多时间开会讨论你的头发，以至于我的猫服装就像是：啊，随便给她套上这个就行了。但你最后大概又穿了那套服装两三次。好几年。好几年。
It was so, and the skirt didn't quite fit me and it kept like heading south. I had to keep like grabbing it and yanking it up. It almost ruined the whole episode, that whole cat. I think now there was such a big meeting about your hair that my cat costume was just like, ah, just put this on her. But you ended up wearing that costume like two more times. For years. For years.
而且它是最差的一套。我隐约有一点记忆，非常非常微弱的记忆，就是在化妆间里听他们讨论要如何区分三只猫。然后决定菲莉丝和我每边的脸颊上要有三根胡须，而你只有两根。我的猫被残害了。我觉得这件事真的发生过。我不知道我们能不能问问拉韦恩（Laverne）。
And it's the worst one. I have a vague memory, a very, very vague memory of being in makeup and having them discuss how they were going to differentiate the three different cats. And it was decided that Phyllis and I would have three whiskers on each cheek and you would only have two. My cat was maimed. I feel like that happened. I don't know if we can ask Laverne.
拉韦恩是我们的化妆师。我不知道。我不知道。但我的意思是，对吧，我只是觉得你……你太小了，不配拥有三根。他们决定少给我一根。在谈到这个场景和会计部时，我必须指出，我们的摄像师平时并不经常做那种全景角色慢摇镜头，
Laverne was our makeup artist. I don't know. I don't know. But I mean, right, I just think you had. You were smaller than you deserve three. They decided to give me less. I have to, while we're talking about this scene and accounting, I have to point out that we don't often, our camera guys didn't often do like a full character slow panned,
你知道吗？他们拍了一个超级搞笑的慢摇镜头。他们从凯文的脚开始，一直摇到他的头，当时他正在归档文件，让他以一身红色的紧身连衣裤亮相。他的袜子鼓鼓囊囊的，在不该鼓的地方鼓了起来。哦天哪。哦，太棒了。太棒了。
you know? And they do such a hilarious one. They start at Kevin's feet and they go all the way to his head while he's filing to get him in full, red leotard. With his socks all miss bulging in wrong areas. Oh my gosh. Oh, that's great. It's great.
这是一个关于凯文的绝妙慢摇镜头。我们得说，我们真的很喜欢穿这些万圣节服装，因为我们平时的衣服通常都很古板。某种程度上就像我们穿着制服一样。我们的服装团队非常、非常喜欢给我们做造型，服装组很喜欢给我们换装，因为平时就是灰色高领毛衣。安吉拉，给我们来张小卡片。好的。
There's a great slow pan of Kevin. We should say we loved dressing up in these Halloween costumes because our outfits normally were pretty boilerplate. It was almost like we wore uniforms in a way. And our wardrobe people loved, loved, the wardrobe crew loved getting to dress us because they, it was just like gray turtleneck. Angela, give us a note card. All right.
在5分23秒时。克里德，这是一个贯穿全剧的梗。这是一个贯穿全剧的梗的延伸，但这可是个大事件。什么？凯利编了双辫。哦！她的头发放下来了。她的头发放下来了。
At five minutes, 23 seconds. Creed, this is a runner. This is a reference to a runner, but this is a really big deal. What? Kelly has braided like pigtails. Oh! Her hair is down. Her hair is down.
她的头发放下来了。哦天哪。我想起来了。她平时不是盘着发髻的。敏迪在几乎整个第一季里都梳着发髻，然后大约在——我猜是开始时。那是一个发卷。一个发卷。我想是一个法式发卷。
Her hair is down. Oh my gosh. I remember. It's not in a bun. Mindy had a bun for like the whole first season and then about, I guess, was starting. It was like a twist. A twist. A French twist, I think.
我的意思是，她看起来……她的角色真的改变了造型。然后她开始把头发放下来，人也变得有点俏皮 sassy 了，但这可是一件大事。我们一直在纳闷，他们是什么时候给她换发型的？这就是开始。我明白了。我觉得这个不算，因为这是万圣节服装。什么？
I mean, she looked, her character really changes her look. And then she starts having her hair down, she gets a little sassy, but this has been a big thing. We've been wondering, when did they change her hair? This is the beginning. I see. I don't think this counts because it's a Halloween costume. What?
是的。我很遗憾地这么说。不，不，我同意。我得说我站在珍娜这边。谢谢。这不算。这不算。好吧，克里德，我不知道我在这里是不是还受欢迎。
Yeah. I'm sorry to say. No, no, I agree. I'm going to have to say I'm with Jenna. Thank you. It doesn't count. It doesn't count. Well, I don't know if I like you here, Creed.
突然之间我有了同盟。哦，好吧。二对一。哦，真扫兴。我当时挺兴奋的，因为她的头发放下来了。但这毕竟是万圣节服装，不是吗？哦，天哪。
All of a sudden I have someone. Oh, well. The dovetoe. Two against one. Oh, fart. I got pretty excited because her hair was down. But it was a costume, though, wasn't it? Oh, my God.
看，这就是我所说的。这不作数。这不作数。我不知道该支持珍娜还是克里德了。这不作数。好吧。你知道潘和吉姆为德怀特制作简历好让他去别处找工作的那个场景吗？
See, that's what I'm saying. It doesn't apply. It doesn't apply. I don't think to Jenna or Creed, I don't know anymore. It doesn't apply. All right. You know the scene where Pam and Jim set up a resume for Dwight to get a job someplace else?
我有一个关于那个场景的粉丝提问。R.C.J.H.问：你和吉姆在弄德怀特的简历时，在电脑上打的是什么？我打的就是我们正在说的话。你当然会那样做，珍娜。你当然会。因为你太沉浸式表演了。我非常沉浸式。
I have a fan question about that. R.C.J.H. asked, what were you typing on the computer when you and Jim were working on Dwight's resume? I was typing what we were saying. Of course you were, Jenna. Of course you were. Because you're so method. I was very method.
你就像在说：我是一个负责任的人。你在演的时候会把台词直接打在电脑上吗？对的，因为吉姆会说，比方说，我会说，我们这里该说点什么？然后他会说我们该说什么，我就把它打出来。而且，看吧。我很为自己的打字速度感到骄傲。哦，我们知道。我们知道。
You're like, I am a responsible person. You would type out your lines on the computer while you were doing it? Yeah, because Jim would say, like, I would say, what should we say here? And then he would say what we should say, and I would type it. And see, here's the thing. I'm very proud of my typing skills. Oh, we know. We know.
是的。克里德，我们是知道还是不知道？我们真的知道。你们这群人。我又回到你这边了，安吉拉。谢谢你，克里德。这就是这种感觉吗？这就是这种感觉。
Yeah. Creed, do we know or do we know? We really know. You guys. I'm back on your side, Angela. Thank you, Creed. This is how it feels? This is how it feels.
我们知道。当你用手指在桌上敲打时，我们在工艺品店谈论事情时，你的手指就会动起来，就像你在打字一样。哦，那可不是真的。那太夸张了，太夸张了，珍娜。收敛一点。然后你就会向我们炫耀你的打字速度和准确率。
We know. When you walk in this thing with your fingers, we'd be talking about stuff at a craft store and your fingers would be going like you're typing. Oh, now that is not true. That was, it was too much. It was too much, Jenna. Tone it down. And then you would tell us about your typing speed and your level of accuracy.
好吧，你们应该知道，我打的确实是我们的真实台词，因为我做得到。好吧，我觉得这挺了不起的。因为她做得到，我也做得到，而且我也会这么做。而且你打字也很快。没错。她打字非常快。当德怀特把德怀特（原文如此，应指迈克尔）叫进办公室，告诉德怀特他必须解雇一个人时，德怀特开始列举所有他认为应该被解雇的人。
Well, you should know I was typing our actual lines because I could. Well, I think that's pretty great though. Because she could and I can and I will. And you're fast too. That's right. She's very fast. I've been with Dwight when he calls Dwight into his office and he tells Dwight that he has to fire someone and Dwight starts naming all the people he should fire.
但随后迈克尔暗示也许应该解雇德怀特。接着迈克尔的第二个脑袋开始和德怀特说话。你们还记得吗，你们还记得史蒂夫和雷恩（Rainn）在那场戏里笑场了吗？因为我记得。我记得他们简直没法把那场戏演完。我当时坐在背景的前台接待处。他们在里面笑得前仰后合。雷恩简直笑得直不起腰，因为他当时有点向前倾身，整个人都
But then Michael implies maybe it should be Dwight. And then Michael's second head starts talking to Dwight. Do you remember, do you remember Steve and Rain laughing during that scene? Because I do. I remember they could not get through that scene. I'm sitting out at reception in the background. And they were cracking themselves up in there. Rain was literally doubling over because he was like kind of leaning forward and he would
快蜷缩起来了。他笑得太厉害了。那个场景肯定有被删减片段。哦天哪，我好想看看那些片段。我好想看。是的。那真是一个搞笑的场景。好吧，保罗·费格在我们制作《办公室奥运会》（Office Olympics）时曾打电话进来，他说他喜欢执导我们节目的其中一个原因，就是你能真正找到一个很酷的镜头，并且会得到格雷格的支持去放手一试。他刚好找到了那个镜头：德怀特作为西斯尊主，头上戴着那种连帽，看起来就像是从电影里直接走出来的一样，你知道吗？是的。
just kind of collapse into himself. He was laughing so hard. There must be deleted scenes of that scene. Oh man, I would love to see those. I would love to see that. Yeah. That is a funny scene. Well, Paul Feig called in when we did Office Olympics and he said one of the things he
他们太喜欢那个了。从侧面拍的镜头，对吧？是的，侧面拍摄的镜头。他们就是找到了那种感觉然后顺势拍了下来。格雷格对此完全给予支持。保罗谈到了拥有这种创作自由并发现这些小巧思是多么有趣。而且画面看起来太酷了。我们有很多这样的镜头。它们不只是那种千篇一律或套路化的情景喜剧镜头。我们拍出了有趣的镜头。
loved about directing episodes of our shows is that you could really find a shot that was cool and you would have the support of Greg to just kind of go with it. And he sort of found that shot where Dwight as the Sith Lord has his like hood kind of like, it looks like it's straight out of the movie, you know? Yes. And they just love that. Shot from the side, right? Yeah, shot from the side.
是的。因为我们的摄像师太棒了。还有一件事我们还没在播客里聊过，那就是演员标记（actor marks）的概念。通常在电视剧拍摄中，为了能拍到这些镜头，他们会在地上贴一小块胶带。如果你——比方说，如果吉姆必须走到潘的桌子前，地上就会有一个小标记，他必须精确地站在那个标记上。这其实很难做到。
And they sort of just found that and went with it. And Greg was totally supportive of it. And Paul was talking about like how fun that was to have that creative freedom and find those little nuggets. And it's so cool looking. We had a lot of shots like that. They're just more at the cookie cutter or a stereotype, you know, sitcom stuff. And we get interesting shots.
他们就顺着这个思路去做了。格雷格非常支持。保罗也谈到拥有这种创作自由并发现这些精彩小细节是多么有趣。画面看起来太棒了。我们有很多这样的镜头，而那些千篇一律的、带有刻板印象的情景喜剧内容则相对较少。我们拍出了很有意思的镜头。
Yeah. Because our cameramen were so great. And something that we haven't talked about on the show yet is the idea of actor marks. So usually on a television show, so that they can get these shots, they put a little piece of tape on the ground. And if you, for example, if Jim had to walk up to Pam's desk, there would be a little mark on the ground and he would have to stand exactly on that mark. And it's really hard to do.
是的。因为我们的摄影师太棒了。我们在节目中还没讨论过的一个概念是演员站位标记。通常在电视剧中，为了拍到这些镜头，他们会在地上贴一小块胶带。如果你，比如说吉姆必须走到帕姆的桌子前，地上就会有一个小标记，他必须准确地站在那个标记上。这其实很难做到。
I mean, do you guys find it hard to do? I'm always, I feel like I'm always looking down for the tape and then I get to my spot and I look up. It's like a hard thing to manage. Well, on our show, we did not have that. They would just let us wander. They would say, just walk up in this general area and the camera will find you. Yeah.
我的意思是，你们大家觉得这很难做吗？我总是，我觉得我总是低头找胶带，然后到了我的位置我再抬起头。这真是一件很难掌控的事情。嗯，在我们的节目里，我们没有那种情况。他们只会让我们到处晃悠。他们会说，就在这片大致的区域走走，摄像机会找到你的。是啊。
It was so loosey-goosey, so amazing. Didn't you say you were in a band called loosey-goosey? I was in a band called loosey-goosey. I was. You were not. I was in a band with Peter White, who used to play with Al Stewart. He probably still does. We had a band with Dave Camp on sax and remember we played the rap party for this movie I did
这太随性了，太棒了。你刚才不是说你在一个叫“随性”（loosey-goosey）的乐队吗？我确实在一个叫“随性”的乐队。我是。你才没有。我曾和彼得·怀特（Peter White）在一个乐队，他以前跟阿尔·斯图尔特（Al Stewart）一起演出。他现在可能还在。我们有个乐队，戴夫·坎普（Dave Camp）吹萨克斯，还记得我们为我拍的那部电影举办过杀青派对吗？
with, worked on with Bo Bridges at the beach house at Lloyd Bridges house, loosey-goosey played out there and they were dancing out there like Annette Funicello and the surf and stuff. Oh my gosh. We just need you to just sit here and tell us about all your stories. Creed, you have literally the most interesting life. I have a fan question for you. I'm a fascinating character.
我跟博·布里奇斯（Bo Bridges）在海滩小屋，在劳埃德·布里奇斯（Lloyd Bridges）的房子里合作过，“随性”乐队在那里演奏过，他们在那儿跳舞，就像安妮特·方尼切洛（Annette Funicello）在冲浪时那样。哦，天哪。我们只需要你坐在这儿，给我们讲讲你所有的故事。克里德，你的人生简直是有史以来最有趣的。我有一个粉丝的问题要问你。我是一个迷人的人物。
You are. And humble too. This is a fan question from Todd Myers and this feels like a good place to ask it. Who is the biggest rock star you ever partied with during your touring days? Oh. Wow. Partied with. It maybe doesn't have to be the biggest.
你确实是。而且还很谦虚。这是一个来自托ッド·迈尔斯（Todd Myers）的粉丝问题，我觉得在这里问很合适。在你的巡演期间，你跟哪个最大牌的摇滚明星一起参加过派对？哦。哇。一起开派对。这倒不一定非得是最最大牌的。
No. What's the most interesting? Yeah. I lived for a while at the Camrose Highland Estates and Linda Ronstadt was there, Laura Nero was there, Jackson Brown used to, there was a lot of people playing at this place and lived there and they would play their instrument. You hear the instruments going around the Cameron Highland Estates and Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers was there and one night Butch came over.
不。最有趣的是什么？嗯。我在卡姆罗斯高地庄园（Camrose Highland Estates）住过一段时间，琳达·朗斯塔特（Linda Ronstadt）也在那儿，劳拉·尼罗（Laura Nero）也在那儿，杰克逊·布朗（Jackson Brown）也经常去，有很多人在那儿弹奏乐器，并在那儿生活。你能听到乐器声在卡姆罗斯高地庄园里回荡，来自奥尔曼兄弟乐队（Allman Brothers）的布奇·特拉克斯（Butch Trucks）也在那儿，有一天晚上布奇过来了。
Wait, wait, wait. I'm so sorry. You all lived together? No. We lived at the Estates in little bungalows. You could rent these bungalows at the Camrose Highland Estates. Now it's been fixed up a little bit. It's right next to the Veterans of War and War place.
等等，等等，等等。非常抱歉。你们住在一起？不。我们住在庄园里的小平房里。你可以在卡姆罗斯高地庄园租这些小平房。现在那里已经稍微整修过了。它就在退伍军人战争纪念馆旁边。
I think they're right on Highland Boulevard, right on Highland Boulevard, right off to get off the freeway. It's right there. And like a lot of artists. A lot of artists were living there. So Butch Trucks from the Almond Brothers came over one night and Griffin from the Bread and Jesse Ed Davis used to play with John Lennon came over one night and we jammed. We jammed for hours and hours and hours and hours and there was a lot of heavyweight
我想他们就在高地大道上，就在高地大道旁边，下了高速公路就到。就在那儿。就像很多艺术家一样。很多艺术家都住在那里。所以奥尔曼兄弟乐队的布奇·特拉克斯有一天晚上过来了，还有曾跟约翰·列侬一起演奏的“面包”乐队的格里芬和杰西·埃德·戴维斯（Jesse Ed Davis）有一天晚上也过来了，我们一起即兴演奏。我们即兴演奏了几个小时又几个小时，那天晚上有非常多重量级的
guitar players there at that night. I remember Butch wanted me to go back to Alabama and be the lead singer for this group, Cowboy, but that never happened. Creed, your life is amazing. Jenna, I don't know that we would have been hip enough to hang out there. We would not. Well, I have a card right here. Tell me.
吉他手在那里。我记得布奇想让我回阿拉巴马州，去当这个组合“牛仔”（Cowboy）的主唱，但这最终没有发生。克里德，你的人生太神奇了。珍娜，我不知道我们当时有没有那个酷劲儿去那里混。我们肯定没有。嗯，我这儿正好有一张卡片。告诉我。
Seven minutes, 44 seconds. Creed, we have some PPC rock. Oh, I've got it down. Pam versus Angela. Angela Sass? Angela Sass, but also same category. What? I get this.
7分44秒。克里德，我们有一些“帕帕克”（PPC）摇滚。哦，我记下来了。帕姆对阵安吉拉。安吉拉·萨斯（Angela Sass）？安吉拉·萨斯，但也是同一类别。什么？我懂了。
So my character says, what, you brought brownies? What did you bring? And you're like, I brought brownies. Brownies. And I'm like, but I brought cookies. Same category. Yeah. Same category.
所以我的角色说，什么，你带了布朗尼蛋糕？你带了什么？然后你说，我带了布朗尼蛋糕。布朗尼蛋糕。然后我说，但是我带了曲奇饼干。同一类别。对。同一类别。
You should have brought something savory. You know, Angela Sass. Is that what you say in the thing? Same category? I say, same category. I remember that. Well, I mean, I feel like there's a backstory missing here. Did you assign me something other than brownies?
你应该带点咸味的点心。你知道的，安吉拉·萨斯。你在里面是这么说的吗？同一类别？我说，同一类别。我记得那个。好吧，我的意思是，我觉得这里少了一个背景故事。你给我分配的任务难道不是别的，而是布朗尼蛋糕吗？
I'm sure I did. That's your implication. Yes. You're implying that I went rogue and brought brownies instead of chips and dip. You clearly did. I clearly at some party planning. Don't you say, where's the chips and dip or something? Yes.
我确信我分配了。这就是你的暗示。是的。你在暗示我自作主张，带了布朗尼蛋糕，而不是薯片和蘸酱。你明明就是。我在某个派对策划会上明明说过……难道你没说，薯片和蘸酱在哪里之类的话吗？是的。
I clearly at some party planning committee meeting said, all right, I will make sugar cookies. Why don't you bring the dip and chips and then you show up with these fricking brownies. How dare you? Wait, Sam, can we see that? Those aren't chips and dip. No, I made brownies. But I'm just trying to figure out why you're sabotaging things.
我在某个派对策划委员会会议上明确说过，好吧，我来做糖霜曲奇。你为什么不带蘸酱和薯片呢，结果你却带着这该死的布朗尼蛋糕出现了。你怎么敢？等等，萨姆，我们能看看那个吗？那些可不是薯片和蘸酱。不，我做了布朗尼蛋糕。但我只是想弄清楚你为什么在搞破坏。
I made brownies. And I made cookies. Same category. All right. After watching that clip, I will admit, I think Pam did go a little rogue. Clearly you assigned me chips and dip. Thank you. Yeah.
我做了布朗尼蛋糕。我还做了曲奇饼干。同一类别。好吧。看完那个片段后，我承认，我觉得帕姆确实有点自作主张了。很明显你分配给我的是薯片和蘸酱。谢谢。是啊。
Thank you. Same category. Yeah. Same category. All right. I needed to hear that because I think, Jenna, if it was your house and you were having a party, you would be like, hey, come on. Yeah.
谢谢。同一类别。对。同一类别。好吧，我需要听到这个，因为我觉得，珍娜，如果那是你的房子，你在办派对，你就会说，嘿，行了吧。是啊。
All right. Guys, I think we should go to a break and then we'll come back and finish the episode. All right. Craig, how are you doing? I'm doing wonderful. Oh my God, I love having you here, Craig. I do too. And we are back with my delightful neighbor and an office favorite, Craig Bratton.
好了。各位，我觉得我们应该先休息一下，然后回来继续这集的节目。好的。克雷格（Craig），你最近怎么样？我过得很好。哦天哪，克雷格，有你在这儿我太高兴了。我也是。我们回来了，和我可爱的邻居、办公室的最爱克雷格·布拉顿（Craig Bratton）在一起。
Thank you. Craig, we're going to make you come back on this podcast all the time. I hope you're ready. Yeah. You know what? We could carpool. We could. I could swing by and pick you up.
谢谢。克雷格，我们要让你以后一直来这个播客做客。我希望你准备好了。是的。你知道吗？我们可以拼车。我们可以。我可以顺车去接你。
There's the lurking, lurking, these office ladies. You guys, do you remember the scene where Jim takes a phone call from a potential employer for Dwight and he does a Michael Scott impression? It's really good. John does a very good job. It's at eight minutes, 34 seconds. Oh, you've got the time code. Guys, is this when we find out that Michael's middle name is Gary?
这就是潜伏，潜伏，这些办公室女士们。你们，大家还记得吉姆替德怀特接听一个潜在雇主电话并模仿迈克尔·斯科特的那个场景吗？真的非常棒。约翰做得非常好。在8分34秒。哦，你连时间码都记下了。各位，这是我们发现迈克尔的中间名叫加里（Gary）的时候吗？
Oh, is this the first time it's said? Because he says Michael G. Scott. Yeah. I don't know. I don't know. Because later it was when we had the scene where we showed him as a little boy and he doesn't get all the love that he wanted because he wanted a family. That's later, right?
哦，这是第一次说出来吗？因为他说的是迈克尔·G·斯科特（Michael G. Scott）。是的。我不知道。我不知道。因为后来我们拍了那个场景，展示他小时候的样子，他没有得到他想要的全部爱，因为他想要一个家庭。那是后来，对吧？
Yeah, yeah. Okay, that was Gary. We knew Gary there. That might be. That might be the first time. I don't know. I'm putting it out there. Our fans will know.
对，对。好吧，那就是加里。我们在那里知道了加里。那可能。那可能是第一次。我不知道。我只是提出来。我们的粉丝会知道的。
Our fans will let us know for sure. I loved the scene. I just thought that John crushed it as Michael Scott and it also had the Jim and Pam air high five. The first. The first. Air high five. Yes.
我们的粉丝肯定会让我们知道的。我喜欢那个场景。我只是觉得约翰把迈克尔·斯科特演得太绝了，而且里面还有吉姆和帕姆的隔空击掌。第一次。第一次。隔空击掌。是的。
I'm getting creeds, getting misty, misty eyes. I've got, I've literally, when I saw it, I think I audibly said out loud to no one. Oh. Yeah. Super cute. Okay. So I have a question about the air high five. Say it.
我都起克里德了，眼眶都湿润了。我真的，当我看到它的时候，我想我自言自语地大声说出来，也没对谁说。哦。是啊。超级可爱。好吧。所以我有个关于隔空击掌的问题。说吧。
So I was trying to do the air high five with my daughter Isabel. Now granted, she's 11. I'm 48. We, we, our timing's off. We couldn't get it. It's difficult. You guys did it perfectly. Yeah.
所以我当时正试着跟我女儿伊莎贝尔（Isabel）击掌。当然啦，她11岁。我48岁。我们，我们的时机不对。我们没对准。这很难。你们当时击得完美极了。是啊。
And you know what? We kind of did it perfectly the first time. That's, it was meant to be. It was meant to be. That was, that speaks to our chemistry, I believe. So shortly after this momentous air high five, very sadly, Pam tells Jim he should go for the job at Cumberland Mills, but the job is in Maryland and he is so hurt. This happens a lot with you guys.
你知道吗？我们第一次就差不多完美地完成了。那是，命中注定的。命中注定。这说明了我们的默契，我相信。所以在这个意义非凡的隔空击掌后不久，非常遗憾地，帕姆告诉吉姆他应该去争取坎伯兰米尔斯（Cumberland Mills）的工作，但那份工作在马里兰州，而且他受到了很大的伤害。你们之间经常发生这种事。
Yeah. Him going off to do a job. It's a recurring theme, right? It is because he's, you know, later he's going to go off to the other branch. And then later to New York and do that stuff with the sports thing, right? Yeah. That kept happening. And then you go to art camp or school or art camp.
是啊。他去外地找工作。这是一个反复出现的主题，对吧？是的，因为他，你知道的，后来他要去另一个分公司。然后又去纽约，和体育事务那边的人一起工作，对吧？是的。这种事一直在发生。然后你去艺术夏令营或者学校，还是艺术夏令营？
I went to a university. Thank you very much. And then she goes to. Art camp. Plaster of Paris making place. Geez. But yes, they constantly are being pushed together and pulled apart, right? Yeah, they are always.
我上的是大学。谢谢啦。然后她去了。艺术夏令营。石膏工艺品制作地。天哪。不过是的，他们不断地被推到一起又被拉开，对吧？对，他们一直是。
Yeah. Always, always. But sometimes just through a comment. We're seeing in this second season, in each episode, there seems to be a really sweet moment with Jim and Pam and then a moment where someone gets their feelings hurt. They're feelings hurt. A little bit. So many feelings.
对，一直，一直。但有时只是通过一句评论。我们在第二季中看到，在每一集中，似乎都有一个吉姆和帕姆之间非常甜蜜的时刻，然后就是一个让某人感情受伤的时刻。感情受伤。有点。太多的感情。
So many feelings. Feelings. But then at the end, Jim admits that if it weren't for Pam, he would take the job at Cumberland Mills because the pay is twice as much. It's a better job. Yada, yada. So why is he staying? He just basically admitted why he stays at this job.
太多的感情。感情。但最后，吉姆承认，如果不是因为帕姆，他就会接受坎伯兰米尔斯的工作，因为薪水是两倍。这是一份更好的工作。诸如此类。那他为什么还要留下来？他基本上承认了自己为什么留在这份工作上。
Yes. Yeah. What was the one where he admitted that crabs are his favorite food? So he was going to go to this. Maryland. Maryland. But that was it. Yeah.
是的。对。哪个场景是他承认螃蟹是他最喜欢的食物来着？所以他本来打算去这个。马里兰。马里兰。但就是这样。对。
That was the crab thing. Yeah. Soft-shelled crabs. Soft-shelled crabs. Are apparently one of his favorites. Yes, exactly. Who knew that? Well, he eats that tuna sandwich every day for lunch.
就是那个关于螃蟹的事。对。软壳蟹。软壳蟹。显然是他的最爱之一。对，没错。谁知道呢？好吧，他每天午餐都吃那个金枪鱼三明治。
We didn't know that. So he is a seafood fan. Yes. So he just stinks all the time. I guess so. And he could have called him crab if he wanted to. Oh, crabby. He eats tuna sandwiches and Pam eats sour cream and onion chips.
我们可不知道。所以他是个海鲜迷。是的。所以他总是臭烘烘的。我想是的。如果他愿意的话，人们也可以叫他“螃蟹”。哦，“螃蟹雷格”。他吃金枪鱼三明治，帕姆吃酸奶油洋葱薯片。
They're a match. Wow. And I eat mung beans apparently. Wow. What is there? The smells in the sauce. I know. Oh, dear.
他们真是天生一对。哇。而我显然在吃绿豆。哇。那儿有什么？酱汁里的气味。我知道。哦，天哪。
All right. So finally, Michael asked for Jim's help and he wants to do some role-playing where he tries to fire someone and that is just a delicious scene. Did you enjoy that one? How did John get through it is what I want to know. And it's like, Steve, it's Michael, it's like, why are you doing that? I'm going to kill myself. And he's like, wait, is this you as you or who are you right now?
好了。最后，迈克尔请求吉姆的帮助，他想进行一些角色扮演，尝试解雇某人，那真是一个绝妙的场景。你喜欢那一幕吗？我就想知道约翰是怎么熬过这一关的。就像是，史蒂夫，我是迈克尔，就像是，你为什么这么做？我要自杀。然后他说，等等，这是你在扮演你自己还是你现在是谁？
What is happening? John has to check in. And this brings us to your big scene creating. Your big scene. Oh, here we are. This is it. After the scene, he calls you in and tell us, break it down for us. What was it like to sit in that chair and now you're going to launch into five pages
这到底是怎么回事？约翰必须核实一下。这就引出了你创作的大场面。你的大场面。哦，我们来了。就是这个。那个场景拍完后，他把你叫进去，告诉我们，给我们剖析一下。坐在那张椅子上的感觉是什么样的，现在你准备跟史蒂夫·卡瑞尔（Steve Carell）
with Steve Carell? Right. Right. I mean, I never had five pages with Steve Carell. Six and a half, you said, six and a half. Six and a half original. They may have cut it down, but it was, it was like, it took a long hours to get through that thing.
对戏足足五页纸？对。对。我的意思是，我从来没有跟史蒂夫·卡瑞尔对过五页纸的台词。你说的六页半，六页半。六页半的原创内容。他们可能删减了一些，但它，就像是，花了很长时间才把那场戏拍完。
And I mean, I never had more than a few lines with him one on one. So yeah, let's, let's hear about it. Well, first of all, there was a scene where I slowly take out the teeth, you know, and I resolve myself. I gird my loins as it were. I stand up within a resolute and I march in like Nesferatu, you know, with a purpose. Are these some of your notes that you wrote in your script? No.
我的意思是，我从来没有跟他的单人对手戏超过几句台词。所以，是的，让我们听听是怎么回事吧。好吧，首先，有一个场景是我慢慢地把假牙拿出来，你知道的，我做好了心理准备。我像人们说的那样束紧腰带。我带着坚决的态度站起来，像诺斯费拉图（Nesferatu）一样大步走进去，你知道的，带着某种目的。这些是你写在剧本里的笔记吗？没有。
I don't know. I don't have any intention. This is just some storytelling, Jenna. It's the, it's the B story. Storytelling. I'm into the story right now. Yeah, exactly. So you march in.
我不知道。我根本没那个意图。这只是一些讲故事的技巧，珍娜。这是，这是B线故事。讲故事。我现在正沉浸在故事里呢。是的，完全如此。所以你大步走了进去。
So I march in and then I, I remember I sit, I sit back like this and I put my cross, my feet, I kind of houch down and I have my arms crossed because I'm protecting myself from attack like this. And he goes, well, I'll create, I just don't like this. I said, well, you want to leave? He says, no, no, I don't. No, Nes, you do. No, no, I don't.
所以我就大步走了进去，然后我，我记得我坐着，我像这样往后一靠，把双脚交叉，我有点蜷缩着，双臂交叉在胸前，因为我要像这样保护自己免受攻击。然后他说，好吧，克里德，我就是不喜欢这样。我说，哦，你想走吗？他说，不，不，我不想。不，诺斯，你想的。不，不，我不想。
You're the hardest person to fire ever. You're going to leave. No, no, really. No, I know I'm very happy here. I said, Creed, I've got, I've got to fire somebody and it's got to be, well, then fire Devon. You know, he's horrible. He's a job, you know, I'm so much better at my job and I'm doing the Creed voice right
你是有史以来最难解雇的人。你要走了。不，不，真的。不，我知道我在这里非常开心。我说，克里德，我必须，我必须解雇某人，而且必须是，好吧，那就解雇德文（Devon）。你知道的，他太糟糕了。他是个工作，你知道的，我比他适合这个工作多了，我现在也在用克里德的声音说话呢。
now too. He goes, it goes up a bit, you know. And then I just thought, I just fought for my survival and we kept doing it over and over and over and finally. And Steve was so great. It's like, you've all done scenes with people where it's forcing it, it's so hard to get through a scene. Yeah.
他的声音会变高一点，你知道的。然后我当时就在想，我只是为了生存而战，我们一遍又一遍、一遍又一遍地拍，最后。史蒂夫真的太棒了。就像是，你们都跟别人拍过那种强行推进、极难熬过去的戏。是的。
Working with Steven was like that. He kept tossing me like these big beach balls and I had a Nerf bat, which is easy. Yeah. It was easy to hit those things, you know. God bless him. He's a very giving person, you know, and when you're in scenes with him, he's so eager for you to get the laugh. He doesn't, some actors, guys out there, they want to get the laugh.
跟史蒂夫合作就是那样。他不断地抛给我各种巨大的沙滩球，而我手里拿着一根海绵棒，这很容易。是的。击打那些球太轻松了，你知道的。上帝保佑他。他是一个非常慷慨的人，你知道的，当你和他在一个场景里时，他非常渴望你能赢得笑声。他不会，有些演员，各位，他们想要博得笑声。
They want that moment. Steve is so eager to share it and really just what makes the scene work is what he focuses on. But Dave Rogers later, he said, he's what made him laugh the most is when I stood up and he said, no, no, you're doing a good job. Good for you. I'm waiting. I'm waiting.
他们想要那个高光时刻。史蒂夫非常渴望分享它，他专注于真正能让场景出彩的东西。但戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）后来说过，真正让他笑得最厉害的是我站起来的时候，他说，不，不，你干得不错。干得好。我在等。我在等。
I'm waiting. I'm waiting. My finger and all that stuff was just off the top of my head. Yeah. When I watched, when I rewatched it, I was like, oh, that is Creed. That is classic. That is just Creed being Creed. Yeah.
我在等。我在等。我的手指和所有那些动作完全都是我临时发挥的。是的。当我看着，当我重新看的时候，我就想，哦，这就是克里德。太经典了。那简直就是克里德在展现自我。是的。
Yeah. That is actually. Yeah. I feel like you've left me voicemails where you're like, hey, I'm going to do it. I may have. I was just stuttering perhaps, too. But you were doing a bit. I was doing a bit.
是的。那真的是。是的。我觉得你以前也给我留过语音信箱，内容就像是，嘿，我要去演了。我可能真的留过。我当时可能也只是在结结巴巴地说话。但你当时在演段子。我当时确实在演段子。
Yeah. No. But still, I look at that with fond memories. It was a great night. And I thank Steve so much for being so gracious as an actor to work with, you know. So after that scene, Michael does fire Devin in a much shorter scene. Devin gets so angry, he announces to the office, if anyone wants to join me at poor Richard's bar.
是的。不。不过尽管如此，我带着美好的回忆看待那段经历。那是一个伟大的夜晚，我非常感谢史蒂夫作为一个演员那么平易近人、那么好合作，你知道的。所以在那个场景之后，迈克尔在另一个短得多的场景里真的解雇了德文。德文气极了，他向全办公室宣布，如果有人想去穷理查酒吧（Poor Richard's bar）加入我。
Poor Richard's bar. Is this the first mention of poor Richard's bar? Well, he says he gives him a chili. He gives him, she says. Yeah. Michael gives him a chili coupon. Yeah. Chili coupon.
穷理查酒吧。这是第一次提到穷理查酒吧吗？嗯，他说他给了他一张辣椒券。他给了他，她说。是的。迈克尔给了他一张辣椒券。是的。辣椒券。
Which is a nice nod back to the dundies. Yeah. He rips it up. Yeah. He rips it up. Yeah. But have we, because we end up mentioning poor Richard's bar over and over again and we go there eventually, but have we mentioned it yet?
这也是对“邓迪奖”（Dundies）的一个很好的致敬。是的。他把它撕了。是的。他把它撕了。是的。但是我们，因为我们最后一次又一次地提到穷理查酒吧，我们最终也去了那里，但是我们之前提到过它吗？
Oh, in the basketball episode, I think Daryl suggests that we all get drinks at poor Richard's. Okay, in that scene though, where Devin invites everyone to poor Richard's, there's three people he does not invite. Oh, yeah, you're right. He lists a bunch of names. Who does he know? It's very personal. Who does he not invite?
哦，在篮球那一集里，我想达里尔（Daryl）建议我们大家去穷理查酒吧喝一杯。好吧，不过在那个场景里，德文邀请所有人去穷理查酒吧时，有三个人他没有邀请。哦，对了，你说得对。他列出了一串名字。他认识谁？这很私人。他没有邀请谁？
It's personal. Who are they? He does not invite Michael. Of course. He does not invite Dwight. He does not invite Angela. He doesn't invite you? Why?
这很私人。他们是谁？他没有邀请迈克尔。当然啦。他没有邀请德怀特。他没有邀请安吉拉。他没有邀请你吗？为什么？
There's nothing. It's an arbitrary. It's an arbitrary. I'm sure I've been, you know, bitchy to him at some point. He didn't. I'm sure. I knew you wouldn't go. Maybe so.
没什么。这是一个随意的。一个随意的决定。我确信我以前在某些时候对他也挺刻薄的。他没。我确信。我知道你不会去的。也许吧。
He might have had a crush on you too. Oh, come on. Oh, he might have. You never know. So he leaves and he smashes a pumpkin. There we go. Pumpkin! Pumpkin!
他可能也对你有点迷恋呢。噢，拜托。哦，他可能真的有。你永远说不准。所以他走了，还砸了一个南瓜。我们走吧。南瓜！南瓜！
Pumpkin! And when we go downstairs, we see Hank, the security guy at the security desk, who was played by Hugh Dane. God rest his- Yes. He passed away a couple of years ago. He was so nice. Yeah.
南瓜！当我们下楼时，我们看到了汉克（Hank），安保桌前的保安，由休·丹恩（Hugh Dane）饰演。愿上帝安息—是的。他几年前去世了。他太好了。是的。
Just a sweetheart. He was great as Hank. His delivery was always perfect. Amazing. Is this the first time we see Hank at the security desk? I think so. It has to be. You guys leave, you know, to go to the dojo, but you don't see him there.
简直是个甜心。他演汉克演得棒极了。他的台词功底总是无可挑剔。太惊艳了。这是我们第一次在安保桌前看到汉克吗？我想是的。应该是的。你们离开，你知道的，去道场（dojo），但你没在那儿看到他。
You don't see him. No. Well, it's brilliant because there he is and he's sitting there and it's another example of introducing a character in an episode where they don't speak, but they will eventually. They will come back. He did that with so many people. He did that with Craig in the warehouse and the Alliance. You just see him in the background watching Dwight Pop out of the box.
你没看到他。不。好吧，这太妙了，因为他就在那儿，坐在那儿，这又是另一个例子：在一个角色不说话的剧集中将其引入，但他们最终会开口。他们会回来的。他对很多人都这么做过。他在仓库里对克雷格以及在《同盟》（The Alliance）里就这样做过。你只能看到他在背景里看着德怀特从箱子里跳出来。
Creed of course, you were in the background forever. And then now Hugh Dane in the background is the security officer. Just so thoughtful. And this thing that I love about our show and we've talked about Creed is that Greg had the audience just start in the middle. He doesn't explain things to you. You discover it as you go. It's not spoon-fed information.
克里德，当然了，你一直在背景里。现在休·丹恩也在背景里担任保安。真是太周到了。我最喜欢我们节目的地方、我们也讨论过克里德的一点是，格雷格（Greg）让观众直接从中间看起。他不会向你解释事情。你在边看边发现。它不是那种填鸭式的信息。
Yes. I love that. I don't think we can end this episode without talking about Michael's list of former costumes. Oh, please list them. Okay. He's really, really bummed the camera crew wasn't there the Halloween before when he was Janet Jackson's boob. Very topical.
是的。我喜欢这样。我觉得我们不能不讨论迈克尔过去的万圣节服装就结束这一集。哦，请把它们列出来吧。好吧。他真的，真的很懊恼摄像组去年万圣节他打扮成珍妮特·杰克逊（Janet Jackson）的胸部时没有在场。非常应景。
He's really bummed you guys missed it when he was Monica Lewinsky's dress. Twice. Yeah, twice. And then he was Monica Lewinsky the year before. And then before that he was OJ Simpson. So where does he pick these people? Yeah. Very topical.
他真的很懊恼你们错了他打扮成莫妮卡·莱温斯基（Monica Lewinsky）裙子的那一次。两次。对，两次。然后前一年他打扮成莫妮卡·莱温斯基。再之前他打扮成O·J·辛普森（OJ Simpson）。所以他到底从哪儿挑的这些人物？是的。非常应景。
Yeah. Great costumes that he was really sad the camera crew missed. I know you're going to want to talk about the very end with Michael and the trick-or-treaters because it's just such a touching moment. All right, Creed. I cried every time I watched it. I did too. I did too.
是的。这些绝妙的服装让摄像组没拍到，他真的很难过。我知道你接下来要谈到最后迈克尔和不给糖就捣蛋的孩子们的场景，因为那真是一个太感人的时刻了。好了，克里德。我每次看都哭。我也是。我也是。
Every time. I was loving the show and then when I got to that episode I was like, he just killed me. I said, oh my God, this is a perfect episode. It's one of them. One of the great ones, you know. Yes. At the end of the episode, Michael goes home and you see him sitting alone very lonely
每一次。我当时正喜欢着这个剧，然后当我看到那一集时，我就想，他简直把我击溃了。我说，哦天哪，这真是一集完美的剧。它是其中之一。伟大的一集，你知道的。是的。在这一集的结尾，迈克尔回家了，你看到他一个人孤零零地坐在
on the couch. And then the doorbell rings and there are trick-or-treaters at the door. And there was a big debate on set about how exactly this scene should play out, about whether or not the kids should be nice to Michael or if they should be annoyed by Michael, how Michael should be with the kids, should he be off-putting, should he be kind. And the writers and producers also, well they also discussed if he should be happy or sad while handing out the candy and they decided that they were going to start on that spy shot of Michael looking sad and lonely all alone on Halloween night.
沙发上显得非常寂寞。然后门铃响了，门口是不给糖就捣蛋的孩子们。片场曾就这个场景该如何上演进行过激烈的争论，讨论孩子们对迈克尔到底是该好点儿，还是该对迈克尔感到厌烦，迈克尔对孩子们又该是什么态度，他是该让人倒胃口，还是该表现得友善。编剧和制片人们还讨论了，他在分发糖果时应该是开心还是难过，他们决定从迈克尔在万圣节之夜孤零零、看起来伤心寂寞的那个偷拍镜头开始切入。
But when he gets to the door, I'm going to cry, it's saying it, he lights up, he makes his silly jokes, the kids laugh. The kids love him. Love him. They love him. And it ends on him making a connection. I just think it is the most kind and heartbreaking, wonderful scene. I think it's moments like this that make the office so special.
但当他走到门前时，天哪，说出来我都要哭了，他整个人亮了起来，开着他那些傻里傻气的玩笑，孩子们都笑了。孩子们爱他。爱他。他们爱他。故事在建立起一种联系中结束。我只是觉得这是最善良、最让人心碎又美妙的场景。我认为正是这样的时刻让《办公室》变得如此特别。
We just spend an entire episode kind of laughing at Michael Scott or finding him annoying, but then in the end he just breaks your heart with his vulnerability. Take them all. Don't, they drop them. Don't worry. Take them all. Take them all. Take them all.
我们刚刚花了一整集的时间来嘲笑迈克尔·斯科特，或者觉得他很烦人，但最后他却用他的脆弱彻底击碎了你的心。全拿去吧。别，他们掉地上了。别担心。全拿去吧。全拿去吧。全拿去吧。
Take them all. Take them all. And they love him. It's all yours, yeah. And that's the first time we saw him just so loving. But really? Don't you think so? At that moment, we saw his heart.
全拿去吧。全拿去吧。他们太喜欢他了。全都是你的，是的。那是我们第一次看到他展现出如此充满爱意的一面。但真的吗？你不这么觉得吗？在那一刻，我们看到了他的心。
We saw his heart come out there at that moment. Well, and you tore me up. And you have to think that Michael is somewhere being a great dad. Yeah. He's a great dad. And I wish we could see that. That's the one thing when we talk about a reunion, obviously, we don't want to tread on hallowed ground that is the office and we don't want to mess with anything that everyone
在那一刻，我们看到了他的心流露了出来。好吧，你把我弄哭了。你肯定会觉得迈克尔在某个地方一定是个好爸爸。是的。他是个好爸爸。我真希望我们能看到那一幕。这就是我们谈到重聚时唯一的一点，很明显，我们不想践踏《办公室》这片神圣的土地，我们也不想搞砸每个人
loves so much. But boy, I would love to see where some of these people are and I would love to see Michael as a dad. Yes. Yes. Do you agree that when you watch that scene, I think more than any other scene I can recall. I see Steve. Yes.
都如此深爱的东西。但是天哪，我真想看看这些人现在都在哪儿，我真想看看迈克尔当爸爸的样子。是的。是的。你同不同意，当你观看那个场景时，我觉得比我能想起来的任何其他场景都要强烈。我看到了史蒂夫。是的。
Mm-hmm. That is Steve handing out candy. Absolutely. Absolutely. Yes. That's the kind of just kind hearted gentleman that he is. Sweet, sweet man. Yeah.
嗯哼。那是史蒂夫在分发糖果。绝对是的。绝对是的。是的。他就是那种心地善良的绅士。甜美，甜美的人。是的。
And I think that's part of the reason too why it hits you that hard, Jenna, because we see our friend and we see the kind person he is that gets to shine through, which often as Michael Scott does not. No, it's not. It's true. It's not. Well, I have one little final piece of trivia. All right.
我想这也是为什么那一幕对你的冲击那么大，珍娜，因为我们看到了我们的朋友，看到了他那种善良的本性得以闪耀，而迈克尔·斯科特通常不会这样。不，确实没有。真的没有。好吧，我还有一个最后的冷知识。好的。
In the credits at the end, as it rolls, over the Diddle Dee logo, which Diddle Dee is Greg's company. His daughter Haley actually drew the picture that says Diddle Dee when she was little. You hear, and it's the only time it ever happens, Dwight's voice say, quiet you. Oh. Really? Yes. Angela.
在最后的演职员表滚动时，在迪迪莉（Diddle Dee）的标志上方——迪迪莉是格雷格的公司。他的女儿海莉（Haley）在她小的时候其实画了那张写着“迪迪莉”的画。你听到了，而且这是唯一一次发生这种情况，德怀特的声音说：“安静点，你。”哦。真的吗？是的。安吉拉。
Do we know why that happened? I think they loved it. They pulled it from earlier in the episode when Dwight is the Sith Lord. It's not the only time that they've done something like that. It's the only time there's dialogue over Diddle Dee. Wow. Oh, I'm kind of moved by that. That's kind of cool, right?
我们知道为什么会这样吗？我想他们很喜欢。他们把它从这一集早些时候德怀特扮演西斯尊主（Sith Lord）的片段里截取了过来。这并不是他们第一次做类似的事情。这是唯一一次在迪迪莉标志上方出现台词。哇。哦，我有点被感动了。这挺酷的，对吧？
Yeah. Quiet you. Quiet you. We did it, guys. We did it. We did it. That was a Halloween episode creed. Thank you.
是的。“安静点，你。”“安静点，你。”我们做到了，伙计们。我们做到了。我们做到了。那是万圣节的一集，克里德。谢谢你。
Thank you so much for coming. But before you go, will you tell us what are you up to now? What are you doing? You have an album and you're touring. I'm touring. I was in Europe, UK, in Scandinavia for a month touring and doing shows. I'm bragging now. Seven sold out shows in the UK went great.
非常感谢你的到来。但在你离开之前，能告诉我们你最近在忙什么吗？你在做什么？你有一张专辑，而且在巡演。我在巡演。我在欧洲、英国和斯堪的纳维亚巡演了一个月，举办了各种演出。我现在是在自夸了。在英国有七场门票售罄的演出，进展非常顺利。
I'm off to Australia, New Zealand in February. And then you did the whole East Coast too because I was texting with you and you were like, yeah. Then I did the East Coast. I had a great tour there too. Yeah. And the fans. And I want to thank all the office fans for coming out and supporting my character
我二月份要去澳大利亚和新西兰。然后你还跑了整个美国东海岸，因为我当时跟你发短信，你说，对。然后我去了东海岸。我在那儿也进行了一次非常棒的巡演。是的。还有那些粉丝们。我要感谢所有前来支持我的角色和我的音乐的《办公室》粉丝们。
and my music. It truly means a lot. I'm having my second childhood now doing this. And by the way, I have a surprise for you, ladies. What is it? I brought, which I think may be the single, if there's going to be a single from my, I'm going to play you a little snippet if you'd like of the album. Can we do this in there?
这真的意义重大。做这件事让我仿佛回到了第二童年。顺便说一句，女士们，我给你们准备了一个惊喜。是什么？我带了一首歌，我觉得这可能是我专辑里的单曲，如果有单曲的话，如果你愿意的话，我可以放一小段给你听。我们可以在这里放吗？
Can I play it right now for you? And you guys, before he plays the song, I just want to encourage you, if creed is coming to a town near you, go see his show. It is fantastic. And apparently he also makes fun of me during it. Quite a bit. Angel, yes. And we are trying to figure out one of your locations where I can come on stage and give
我现在就能放给你们听吗？各位，在他放歌之前，我只想鼓励大家，如果克里德去到你附近的城镇，一定要去看他的演出。太棒了。而且显然他在演出中还拿我开涮。相当多。安吉拉，是的。我们正试图找出你的一个演出地点，好让我能上台当场回敬你。人们在哪里可以找到演出日程？creedbratton.com。我们爱你的，克里德。好吧。
it to you right back. Where can people find the schedule? creedbratton.com. We love your creed. All right. Let's hear it. Here we go. You taught me how, you taught me then, how I could one day be your friend.
听听看吧。我们开始。你教会了我怎么做，你当时教会了我，我有一天会如何成为你的朋友。
It's not so hard, just don't lie, don't control, then by and by, we'll be side by side, we'll be side by side, for what's left of the ride. All right. That's that song. There it is, gang. What do you think? Well, Angel is sobbing. I'm, I just started crying.
这其实不难，只要不撒谎，不控制，那么渐渐地，我们就会并肩而行，我们就会并肩而行，为了这趟旅程剩下的部分。好了。就是那首歌。就是这样，各位。你们觉得怎么样？好吧，安吉拉在啜泣。我，我刚刚开始哭。
The song is so beautiful, creed, but also, and I totally am emotional, but oh my God, it might be too emotional. Oh. Well, you know what? It just, do you ever have just like a wave hit you where you're like, you know, you're in a special moment? Yeah. Yes.
这首歌太美了，克里德，而且，我完全充满情绪，但是哦天哪，这可能情绪太满了吧。哦。好吧，你知道吗？这只是，你有没有过那种犹如浪潮般袭来的感觉，让你觉得，你知道的，你正身处一个特殊的时刻？是的。是的。
And it just hit me. Well, I'm like, contaved with the two of you today. Yeah. I feel like we're in a special moment now. It just felt really special and like something I'll always remember and I'm facing my best friend who is now my boss lady business partner and I'm so proud of us and, and this journey we've taken together. And then I just love you, creed.
它刚刚向我袭来。好吧，我今天和你们俩在一起，真的备受触动。是的。我觉得我们现在正处于一个特殊的时刻。这感觉真的非常特别，就像是一件我会永远铭记的事情，而且我正面对着我最好的朋友，她现在是我的老板女士、商业合作伙伴，我为我们感到骄傲，也为我们一起走过的这段旅程感到骄傲。然后，我只是爱你，克里德。
Oh, I love you, sweetie. You're like, you know. Well, now I'm, well, I, ladies and gentlemen, when I, the last album I did, I had a song called more than you know. And I, one of the first people I ever played it for was for you and Josh, you know, it's your house and I came over and acoustically played it and you know, I, and she got, and she started crying. I started crying.
哦，我爱你，甜心。你就像是，你知道的。好吧，现在我，女士们先生们，当我做上一张专辑时，我有一首歌叫《超出你的想象》（More than you know）。我第一个播放这首歌的人之一就是你和乔许，你知道的，在你们家，我过去用木吉他弹奏了它，你知道的，我，她听着听着就哭了。我开始哭了。
I knew I had a winner then. Well, creed, some of my favorite memories on the set were at lunchtime when you would play guitar and Ed would play banjo. Banjo. Yeah. Ed's trailer was next to mine. Yeah. And the two of you would play through my lunch and you guys would call, you would come over
我当时就知道我写出了一首好歌。好吧，克里德，我在片场最美好的回忆之一就是午休时间你弹吉他和埃德（Ed）弹班卓琴的时候。班卓琴。是的。埃德的房车就在我隔壁。是的。你们两个在我的午休时间一直弹，你们俩会过来，
and take your hand in and listen. We'd come over and hang out for years. My alarm clock is banjo music because it would make me think of you guys. And sometimes, especially when I was pregnant, if we had a little break, I might take a cat nap and I'd wake up to banjo music and it was like so pleasing that I made my alarm clock banjo because I thought, oh, maybe I won't wake up grumpy. Ed and I had so much fun. He's a great banjo player.
过来坐在一起听。我们过去一起厮混了很多年。我的闹钟铃声就是班卓琴音乐，因为这会让我想起你们。有时，尤其是当我怀孕的时候，如果我们有短暂的休息时间，我可能会打个盹，然后我会在班卓琴音乐中醒来，它是那么悦耳，以至于我把闹钟设置成了班卓琴，因为我想，哦，也许我醒来时就不会那么暴躁了。我和埃德玩得太开心了。他是个出色的班卓琴手。
I haven't played with him in a long time because we're working all the time, but I would love to. Oh, yeah. You guys were great together. He's the best. Well, thank you again, Creed. Thank you so much for having me, my dear friends. Creed, can we end with a final fan question?
我好久没跟他一起演奏了，因为我们一直在忙工作，但我很乐意。哦，是的。你们俩在一起合作得太棒了。他是最棒的。好吧，再次谢谢你，克里德。非常感谢邀请我，我亲爱的朋友们。克里德，我们能以一个最后的粉丝问题来收尾吗？
Yes, of course. This is from Tim Blair. Tim asked, do you have a favorite creed line from the whole show? Which one's Pam? Which question, Pam? Yes. Oh, gosh, I don't know. It probably would be someone making soup or which one's Pam or, but I think, actually,
好的，当然。这是来自蒂姆·布莱尔（Tim Blair）的提问。蒂姆问，在整部剧中你有没有最喜欢的克里德台词？哪一句是帕姆的？哪个问题，帕姆？是的。哦，天哪，我不知道。大概会是“谁在做汤”或者“哪一个是帕姆”，但我认为，实际上，
I would have to be. In the 60s, I made love to many, many women, often outdoors in the rain and the mud. It's possible a man slipped in. There'd be no way of knowing. Yes. Yes, applause from the booth, and that is how you end an episode, my friend and me. Thank you, Creed. Thank you, Creed.
我最喜欢的应该是。在60年代，我跟许多许多女人做过爱，通常是在户外的雨中和泥地里。很可能有个男人也混进去了。根本无从知晓。是的。是的，演播室里响起了掌声，这就是如何为一集节目画上句号，我的朋友和我。谢谢你，克里德。谢谢你，克里德。
Oh, everyone, please join us next week when we will be talking about the fight. The fight. Yeah. I'll miss you, Creed. You have to come back. Well, I'd love to come back. Okay. Okay.
哦，各位，请下周加入我们，我们将讨论《决斗》（The Fight）。《决斗》。是的。我会想念你的，克里德。你一定要回来。好吧，我很乐意回来。好的。好的。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Peefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episode's candy bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔（Cody Fisher）。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·皮弗（Sam Peefer）。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《橡胶树》（Rubber Tree）。想要收听无广告版本的节目以及我们的彩蛋节目“糖果袋”，请访问StitcherPremium.com。若想免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。